incrementaremos la protección de nuestra
infraestructura crítica a la luz del
Sabotaje de las oleductos nordstring y
aumentaremos y sostendremos nuestro
respaldo por Ucrania
para poder continuar para que ellos
puedan seguir defendiéndose y liberar el
territorio de la ocupación rusa
Ucrania tiene el embrión y seguirá
obteniendo Gracias significativas Aunque
Rusia
este está acudiendo ataques horribles
contra civiles y contra infraestructura
crítica
el presidente Putin está fracasando en
Ucrania
su intento de anexión la movilización
parcial y retórica nuclear y responsable
representa
el escalamiento más significativo desde
el inicio de la guerra y muestran que
esta guerra no va como ha sido planeado
la otan no es parte
nuestro respaldo es vital en este
conflicto los aliados siguen Unidos el
respaldo de Ucrania de su soberanía y de
su defensa
el ministro de defensa de Ucrania
sirénico se unirá a nosotros mañana
tanto
para el grupo de contacto european el
lidera para Estados Unidos y por la y
para la cena de los ministros de
orotanos juntos
discutiremos las necesidades urgentes de
Ucrania doy la bienvenida a los anuncios
recientes por parte de aliados
que brindarán más defensas aéreas y
otras capacidades Ucrania
y espero que lleguen más entregas
nuestro mensaje es claro
la otan está de lado de Ucrania
por el tiempo que tomen
el presidente inició esta guerra y él
debe terminarla
al retirar sus fuerzas de Ucrania
y el presidente lukashenko debería dejar
de ser cómplice con Bielorrusia en este
conflicto legal
este jueves
tendré una reunión regular sobre el
grupo de planeación nuclear el propósito
fundamental del disuasor nuclear de la
otan siempre ha sido preservar la paz
prevenir la coerción y disuadir la
agresión la próxima semana la otan
tendrá su ejercicio
de disuasión esto es entrenamiento
rutinario ocurre cada año
Busca mantener en nuestras disuasiones
efectivas a salvo
las amenazas nucleares veladas del
presidente putinson y responsables
Rusia sabe
que la guerra nuclear no puede ser
ganadas y no debe ser luchada
estamos monitoreando de cerca las
fuerzas nucleares rusas no hemos visto
ningún cambio en la postura rusa
pero estamos vigilantes
en la Cumbre de Madrid de junio
nada del Hotel lideró un cambio
fundamental en nuestra defensa y
disociación para responder a las nuevas
realidades de seguridad
hemos duplicado el número de grupos de
batalla de la otan en la alianza este
pueden ser incrementados a un talla de
brigada También estamos incrementando el
número de las fuerzas de respuesta
rápida
en este encuentro tomaremos decisiones
para hablar de suministros municiones
para aumentar la velocidad de despliegue
de nuestras capacidades de utilizarla el
proceso de planeación de defensa del
otan para que la industria tenga la
demanda necesaria para aumentar la
producción
también nos dirigiremos a la protección
de la infraestructura crítica la otan
estado trabajando en esto por muchos
años
y tras el Sabotaje del oleducto
hemos mejorado nuestra vigilancia en
todos estos territorios
hemos duplicado en nuestra presencia en
el mar Báltico y el mar del Norte a unas
30 naves respaldadas por patrullas
marítimas aéreas y capacidades
subacuáticas
estos esfuerzos están coordinados de
cerca
por el comando marítimo de la tana
los aliados también están incrementando
la seguridad alrededor de instalaciones
claves y aumentando la inteligencia Y
la información
estamos jugando pasos para fortalecer
nuestra resiliencia y nuestra
infraestructura crítica cualquier ataque
deliberado en contra de nuestros aliados
o de su infraestructura crítica será
enfrentado con una respuesta unida y
determinada
nuestra última sesión se enfocará en las
misiones y operaciones de los otan desde
kosovo steirak
nos acompañarán el representativo el
representante borre el de la Unión
Europea porque la otan y la Unión
Europea enfrenta los mismos desafíos de
seguridad tenemos un invierno difícil
por venir es muy importante que
Norteamérica y que Europa sigan Unidos
en respaldo de Ucrania
y defensa de nuestro pueblo eso y listo
para responder sus preguntas
empezamos allí con dolcebelle
Muchas gracias señor secretario general
usted dice que estará tomando decisiones
en este encuentro sobre Cómo incrementar
el Arsenal nacional mientras se le
brinda más Ucrania pero por ejemplo en
el tema de las defensas aéreas misiles
de aire aire son cosas que Alemania debe
ordenar para sí misma Sony ha mandado
todo su cargamento de llave le hizo
Kenia está usted preocupado de que
mientras los aliados están suministrando
Ucrania con todo lo que se pueda puedan
quedar sin protección en casa
Qué podría cambiar esto después de este
encuentro en términos de manufactura y
en términos de producción de estos
armamentos los aliados de la otan han
brindados respaldos sin presentes a
Ucrania
con capacidades armas munición distintos
tipos de respaldo militar Y eso es algo
que por supuesto
damos la bienvenida y hemos animado y
hemos importado desde la otan desde
que inició la invasión de hecho hicimos
esto antes de la invasión hay que
recordar que los aliados de la otan han
brindado respaldo ucranias de 2014
incluyendo entrenamiento el
entrenamiento de escenas de miles de
soldados y oficiales ucranianos están
jugando un rol importante en la defensa
de la
agresión rusa los aliados han respondido
por supuesto buena parte del respaldo
que los alias del Hotel han brindado los
yavelins las defensas aéreas la munición
que se ha brindado Ucrania eso ha sido
tomado desde
un inventario existencia eso significa
que se han reducido su inventario pero
eso es lo correcto Porque es importante
para todos nosotros que Ucrania gane
la batalla y la guerra
en contra de las fuerzas rusas invasoras
porque sí putingana no significa
solamente
una gran derrota para los ucranianos
sino una gran derrota y un gran peligro
para nosotros Porque hará que el mundo
sea más peligroso y nos hará más
vulnerable
a las otras agresiones rusas por eso es
que hemos utilizado el inventario de la
otan y el inventario de otros países
para brindar el respaldo Ucrania por
supuesto Mientras más dure esa guerra es
más importante que podamos
volver a estos inventarios por eso es
que nos estamos dirigiendo a esta
situación Cómo podemos aumentar la
producción para poder producir más para
aumentar nuestros inventarios pero
también respaldar Ucrania Espero que los
ministros tomen decisiones
en la reunión Ministerial de mañana y el
día después de mañana
sobre cómo utilizar el proceso de
planeación de la otan
para acordar
unas vetas más ambiciosas por ejemplo en
distintas capacidades la posibilidad de
incrementar
los objetivos de los seminarios eso
brindarán Industrial con una demanda a
largo plazo que necesitan para invertir
en nuevas capacidades de producción
porque podrían incrementar la producción
parcialmente utilizando
pues capacidades actuales de producción
mucho más e incluso pero para
incrementar esa producción necesitan más
inversiones también esperamos que se
llegue un acuerdo sobre cómo
fortalecer nuestra interoperabilidad
para que los aliados puedan trabajar
juntos de manera conjunta comprar
también munición
parcialmente para
aumentar el inventario pero también para
compartir las capacidades entre aliados
el único proceso de planeación de los
otan creo que es la meta más importante
para asegurarnos que los aliados esa
coordinados y brinden
la demanda de largo plazo para que la
industria aumente su producción vamos
aquí a social
tengo una pregunta sobre la
infraestructura Alemania
Cómo puedo decirlo
duchaban tenía sus todos sus
comunicaciones interrumpidas el fin de
semana hubo cortes de transportes en el
norte del país también hemos visto fugas
con los elementos
Alemania
En qué punto esto es ataques Lo siento
esos incidentes se convierten en actos
de guerra y cómo responde la otan a esto
como una alianza colectiva Usted dijo
que los aliados responderían Pero cómo
se hace de ese tipo de instancia Muchas
gracias
el año pasado durante los últimos años
la otan
ha implementado la mayor transformación
de la defensa colectiva es de la Guerra
Fría parte de esto es tomar
completamente en cuenta las amenazas
híbridas y las amenazas cibernéticas eso
también se declaró hace unos años que
las y los ataques híbridos pueden
activar el artículo 5 y considerarse un
ataque contra un Aliado del otan hemos
aumentado
nuestro trabajo en resiliencia la
protección de infraestructura crítica
estamos conduciendo más ejercicios tanto
la amenazas híbridas como en amenazas
cibernéticas y estamos cambiando
nuestras buenas prácticas y hemos
acordado líneas guía para la protección
de infraestructura críticas todo esto es
para proteger por ejemplo
capacidad de subacuáticas
infraestructura subacuática de productos
cables pero también por supuesto
energía producción energética
infraestructura de transporte no puedo
comentar en eso sí sientes en específico
porque hay investigaciones en curso creo
que tenemos que esperar el resultado de
esta investigación antes de hacer
cualquier juicio final pero en general
puedo decir que por supuesto estamos
monitoreando de cerca
cada incidente que pueda constituir una
amenaza híbrida deducir ataque en contra
de nuestros aliados de la otan estamos
listos para tomar las medidas necesarias
de ser necesario
exactamente qué medida depende de la
naturaleza del ataque nunca le daremos a
nuestro adversario la el privilegio de
definir exactamente Cuál es el umbral de
la activación del artículo 5 Esa será
una decisión que tomamos nosotros como
aliados que tendrá en cuenta
el contexto preciso la situación
específica Que estaremos enfrentando
si hay un ataque híbrido un ataque
contra ataque contrariados
Muchas gracias
secretario general
podrían Los Americanos y bueno de
acuerdo con los estadounidenses
soluciones hubo un ataque en Ucrania
este ataque fue planeado
no tuvo nada que ver es esa Alianza con
el puente de creerch algunos a la lista
dicen que Ucrania no ha tenido nada que
ver con el incidente del puente que fue
solamente usado Como un pretexto para
estos ataques
comparte la otan esta postura cree usted
que este es un punto determinante de
esta guerra que podría cambiar en el
campo de batalla y un pequeño
seguimiento a la pregunta del Terry
usted dice que los ministros discutirán
como
rellenar estos inventarios pero la
guerra ha estado ocurriendo por siete
meses porque eso no se hizo antes Muchas
gracias
la primera pregunta por supuesto
está el diálogo con la industria y con
los distintos aliados sobre Cómo
aumentar la producción
y
bueno rellenar nuestros inventarios
el encuentro de los directores del
momento del Hotel ocurrió Hace unos días
Ese trabajo está en curso pero cuando
los ministros se encuentran mañana habrá
una gran oportunidad para
hablar de lo que se ha logrado en
términos de inventario lo que podemos
lograr a la hora de aumentar la
producción pero también tomar decisiones
nuevas sobre cómo asegurarnos
de no estar solamente
utilizando inventarios existencias sino
realmente aumentar la producción
necesitamos aumentar la producción de
munición de armas
para asegurarnos de la disuasión en la
defensa
de nuestros aliados Sí pero también para
tener más para seguir en el largo plazo
respaldando cráneo
solamente para prevenir males entendidos
el trabajo lo empieza ahora sino que
ella ha estado ocurriendo desde hace un
buen tiempo pero mientras más se alargue
la guerra en Ucrania
ese trabajo con la industria se hace
cada vez más importante porque necesita
decisiones necesitan
la planeación del proceso de planeación
de defensa procesos decisiones objetivos
para asegurarnos de hacerlas inversiones
correctas para poder producir más la
pregunta de la siguiente fue sobre cómo
los ataques de ayer cambia la situación
en el campo de batalla creo que lo que
vimos ayer es una señal de debilidad
Porque la realidad es que ellos no
pueden lograr Progreso en el campo de
batalla Rusia está perdiendo en el campo
de batalla están cediendo territorio
porque no tienen las capacidades
stop de detener las fuerzas ucranianas
que están avanzando
en la manera en la que puedes responder
es haciendo ataques indiscriminados
sobre la ciudad ucranianas
ataques sobre civiles sobre
infraestructura crítica Y por supuesto
esto causa sufrimiento esto hiere a
Ucrania pero de muchas maneras es un
reflejo de la falta de alternativas para
el presidente Putin Ellos están
perdiendo terreno están perdiendo el
embrión y tienen que volver
a ataques de misiles ataques aéreos de
una manera que vimos ayer y hecho hoy
también
la otra pregunta
Rusia ha conducido ataques similares al
inicio de la guerra
por supuesto lo hemos visto en un tiempo
ha pasado un tiempo
y otras ciudades en la parte occidental
del país pero hemos visto ataques sobre
ciudades como gerson
y en otras partes de Ucrania también
regularmente Entonces ellos tienen estas
capacidades exactamente cuando estos
ataques fueron planeados no voy a hacer
detalles pero la realidad es que no
cambia la naturaleza del ataque sos un
ataques en contra
de ciudades civiles que han muerto la
incertidumbre y la infraestructura civil
es blanco y esto es inaceptable
eso es algo que va en contra de la ley
internacional
quisiera preguntar por los ejercicios
nucleares
hubo alguna discusión entre los aliados
sobre si esto era una buena idea
practicar
el uso de armas nucleares de a pesar de
las amenazas de Rusia
y el potencial de un malentendido mal
cálculo
en segundo lugar será este ejercicio
distintos de años pasados debido al
contexto por supuesto increíblemente
importante estoy al tanto de que es un
ejercicio anual es rutinario eso se
entiende Pero estoy preguntando sobre si
una discusión al interior de la alianza
sobre si este Era realmente el buen
momento para hacerlo
ahora es el momento correcto para ser
firme y para ser claro de que la otan
está ahí para proteger y defender a sus
aliados
esto es un ejercicio planeado a largo
plazo planeado antes de la invasión de
Ucrania
es un ejercicio rutinario y es un
ejercicio que busca asegurar que nuestro
disosor nuclear permanezca seguro y
efectivo
10 ejercicios hace algunos años hemos
sido abiertos alrededor de este
ejercicio y creo
enviaría una señal bastante correcta así
de repente hoy cancelamos una
ejercicio planeado rutinario por la
guerra en Ucrania eso sería una señal
equivocada Debemos entender
el comportamiento firme predecible no
está en nuestra fortaleza militar es la
manera correcta de prevenir un
escalamiento
estamos ahí para preservar la paz para
impedir escalamientos y para impedir un
ataque en contra de los países aliados
si ahora
creamos la posibilidad de un
malentendido o mal cálculo por parte de
Moscú respecto a nuestra capacidad de
defender a los aliados incrementaríamos
el riesgo de un escalamiento Y eso es lo
último que queremos
radio por acá
secretario general
hay sugerencias por parte de algunos
políticos varios estados miembros
a la luz de los ataques de ayer y de hoy
sobre la infraestructura crítica y la
infraestructura civil
que es momento de llamar a Rusia como un
estado terrorista estaría usted
dispuesto a decir que Rusia es un estado
que patrocina el terrorismo la segunda
pregunta es también sugerencias
considerar la Cumbre de líderes de la
otan
estamos consultando constantemente entre
aliados de La otan solamente hemos
conducido tres Cumbres este año
recomendaremos una Cumbre cuando sea
necesario cuando tengamos los encuentros
que necesitamos cuando lo necesitamos
estamos
siempre el valor de la posibilidad de
ser Cumbres para asegurarnos de tener
consultas
y las medidas correctas por parte de la
otan en todos los niveles
tendremos un encuentro ministerial esta
semana Y eso brindará una buena
oportunidad enviar un mensaje claro y
luego tomaremos decisiones
sobre Cumbres potenciales cuando sea que
creamos que el tiempo es correcto
[Música]
luego sobre la naturaleza de la guerra
bueno
esta
es una invasión ilegal sobre otro país
es una violación Clara de la ley
internacional
Rusia invadió un estado soberano
independiente violó su integridad
territorial y su soberanía
eso no empezó realmente
en 2022 en febrero de este año empezó en
por supuesto es un escalamiento de
acciones en contra de Ucrania en febrero
violaciones de la ley internacional de
una manera descarada y también
se ha visto ataques horrendos en contra
de civiles
hemos visto los reportes de lucha de
muchos lugares en Ucrania
lo importante ahora es que
todos los hechos estén disponibles que
tengamos una investigación completa Los
aliados de La otan respaldan las
investigaciones en curso y que aquellos
responsables sean los responsables
finales de estas atrocidades
secretario dos preguntas la primera
ese bueno el puente sobre el estrecho de
kerch
es una es una blanco militar legítimo en
su perspectiva incluye eso también un
ataque terrorista
en segundo lugar cuando usted habla de
incrementar el respaldo a Ucrania
Menciona los sistemas de defensa aéreo
Qué tipo de sistemas aéreos de defensa
que necesitan ahora que no han recibido
para lidiar con esa situación Muchas
gracias
necesita una amplio Rango de sistemas
por supuesto y mucho de armas letales
artillería vehículos
a vehículos armados y sistemas de
defensa aéreo todas las armas antitan
que pero también por supuesto
respaldo no le tal como combustible
ropa de invierno sistemas de
Comunicaciones
y muchos tipos distintos de respaldo esa
es la razón por la cual debemos
encontrarnos en el encuentro de mañana
liderado por Estados Unidos pero también
en el encuentro Ministerio de la otan
tendremos la posibilidad
de detallar de discutir distintas listas
y cotejar estas listas de necesidades
entre Ucrania y los aliados de La otan
sobre lo que se puede proveer y eso es
lo que va a ocurrir en este marco ya
ocurrido en los últimos meses es la
razón por la cual hemos podido movilizar
tanto respaldo de aliados de La otan y
de otros socios
hay necesidad urgente de defensas Arias
Pero por supuesto de muchas otras
capacidades
munición de precisión guiada
y otros sistemas avanzados estamos
viendo que esto marca una diferencia
estamos viendo que los soldados
ucranianos pueden utilizar estos
sistemas modernos
de una manera muy efectiva
logrando victoria de hacer el campo de
batalla
por supuesto No se trata solo de agregar
y agregar sistemas se trata de asegurar
que tenemos El combustible las
municiones para
alimentar esos sistemas existentes ya
que la guerra sigue andando la logística
los suministros
de reemplazos de municiones de
combustibles todos sean entregados esto
se hace cada vez más importante
necesitan casi que de todo en nuestros
aliados están brindando un respaldo sin
precedentes porque entienden
qué tenemos una obligación moral
política y de seguridad
de seguro es que Ucrania gane la guerra
contra el presidente lo lamento falta
una pregunta
bueno en primer lugar creo que tenemos
que recordar el punto de inicio de esta
discusión
fue ilegalmente anexada por Rusia
escribe a pertenece a Ucrania los
Aliados del otan y han dejado Claro que
nunca reconocerán La anexión ilegal de
crimea
y fue Rusia quien empezó esa guerra el
presidente Putin empezó esta guerra
[Música]
bueno no voy a entrar en detalles de
quién estuvo detrás del ataque
de ese puente dejaré que Ucrania comete
eso político
Muchas gracias Lili de político tengo
dos preguntas breves volviendo al tema
de las defensas aéreas de las próximas
semanas el corto plazo cree usted que
los aliados de lata tenga la capacidad
de brindarle Ucrania todas las defensas
todos los sistemas de defensa quiere
estar pidiendo está esperando usted de
otros anuncios en los próximos días la
segunda pregunta es más hacia el futuro
las presiones domésticas en Rusia Qué
tipo de planeación
le permitirá la otana ver la idea de que
el presidente Putin deje el cargo y el
desestablecimiento que siga después es
algo que están discutiendo
en los últimos días hemos tenido dos
nuevos anuncios de los Aliados del otan
desde Alemania y desde los Estados
Unidos para brindar más
sistemas de defensa aérea avanzados
los alemanes anunciaron ayer
la amo la bienvenida a ese anuncio
Estados Unidos ha anunciado más entregas
y también sabemos
que han anunciado que están listos para
brindar y entregar Nelson
uno de esos sistemas avanzados y que
Ucrania ya ha recibido Durante los
últimos meses y de nuevo necesitamos más
también más municiones para estos
sistemas la bienvenida a los aliados que
hacer eso sus defensas de sistemas de
defensa aérea están marcando la
diferencia
Porque muchos de sus misiles
son interceptados por los sistemas de
defensa aéreografía los brindados por
los aliados de La otan
por supuesto mientras
no todos sean detenidos se necesita más
y vamos a dirigirnos este tema en el
encuentro de esta semana mañana
con el ministro de los seres nicoff
Cómo asegurarnos de la entrega inmediata
a esos sistemas pero también de brindar
entrenamiento reemplazos y munición para
las capacidades de defensa aérea había
una pregunta más
en primer lugar creo que tenemos que
estar preparados para el largo plazo no
quiero especular mucho sobre
la situación doméstica y política
en Rusia
sin importar
los distintos análisis que puedan
indicarlo creo que lo que debemos
hacerlo también es estar preparados
para todas las actualidades cuando se
trata de Ucrania a seguir respaldándoles
el próximo mes hay una encuentro
importante del Consejo de Seguridad al
extender la misión gritar de la Unión
Europea en voz de arzegovina ahora Rusia
podría poner algo podría cambiar algo
esta situación está usted preocupado por
la situación herzegovina Generalmente
Cuál es la situación de seguridad de los
balcanes que Creen ustedes Muchas
gracias
por supuesto estamos haciendo
seguimiento a la situación en los
balcanes occidentales muy de cerca y
aliados que están ahí en países los
bacanes occidentales y hacen parte de el
aumento del pie de fuerza de la otan ahí
en esa región incluimos recientemente
macedonia al norte y Montenegro la otan
tiene una historia en los bancarios
occidentales queremos terminar con las
brutales guerras étnicas incluyendo la
guerra por supuesto tenemos presencia en
los bacanes occidentales
con nuestra misión en kosovo también el
respaldo a los
a la sede del hotel para la operación al
fea no quiero especular sobre si
el mandato de la operación y por altea
será renovado o no
No es el interés de nadie que este
acuerdo no se ha renovado porque la
Unión Europea la presencia de la Unión
Europea con el respaldo de la otan esta
ayudando a enfrentarse a esos desafíos
que enfrenta Bosnia herzegovina hay
muchas preocupaciones por supuesto hay
muchos desafíos que enfrentamos todos
pero si reducimos la presencia
internacional
bueno de altea o la presencia
internacional el Bosnia la situación que
ya es difícil será más difícil